[Aplausos]
[Música]
bielorrusia no solo es considerada la
última dictadura de europa y el último
país en el que se aplica de forma
efectiva la pena de muerte en el viejo
continente
[Música]
también es un país en el que un día te
puedes montar tranquilamente en un avión
y que de repente en pleno vuelo el
aparato de la vuelta para que la fsb la
antigua cajeme rusa sí si habéis
escuchado bien detenga a empresarios que
no han pasado por el aro todo por obra y
gracia del mismísimo alexander
lukashenko
este hombre lleva ojo desde 1994
presidiendo el país son ya más de 25
años todo un logro para un candidato
independiente que presume de no haber
tenido partido político alguno detrás de
él desde 1992 y es que amigos amigas de
visual político el partido es
básicamente el mismo
las siete poder de lukashenko parece
infinita este pequeño sátrapa aprendiz y
heredero de los peores mecanismos de
control político de la unión soviética
no parece que tenga intención de
marcharse de momento ya ha anunciado que
se va a presentar a la reelección en
2020 después de cosechar un éxito
arrollador en las elecciones
legislativas de 2019 para que os hagáis
una idea de los 110 miembros de la
cámara de representantes de bielorrusia
la oposición consiguió 0 diputados
si lo habéis escuchado bien pero
diputados para que guardar las
apariencias
el resultado fue 89 diputados
independientes simpatizantes de
lukashenko y 21 diputados repartidos
entre partidos que sorpresa también
apoyaban a lukashenko vamos lo que se
dice a arrasar al más puro 'estilo kim
jong-un
el caso es que por cosas como esta y
también claro está por la represión y la
persecución política las abducciones las
violaciones a la libertad de expresión y
los derechos humanos hay motivos más que
de sobra para considerar a bielorrusia
como una dictadura con todas las letras
[Música]
una dictadura que tiene unos lazos
históricos estrechísimos con rusia y no
sólo hablamos de las similitudes
políticas y de modus operandi del
régimen sino también de una herencia
cultural histórica y hasta lingüística
común
por eso hoy en este vídeo os vamos a
hablar del que ha sido todo un curioso
romance internacional que sin embargo
ahora está pasando por su peor momento
bielorrusia y rusia son como dos novios
eternamente prometidos y a punto de
casarse que parece se están
arrepintiendo en el último momento
queréis saber más sobre esta disparatada
historia apuesto a que sí atentos
[Música]
los vecinos de bielorrusia entre dos
polos opuestos amigos que hay algo claro
en bielorrusia es que su situación
geopolítica es extremadamente complicada
hablamos de un país se encastrado entre
dos poderosos bloques hostiles entre sí
la unión europea y rusia-
[Música]
por un lado rusia la madre rusia ha sido
el sustento del país desde su
independencia de la unión soviética
básicamente en la escena internacional
la bielorrusia de lukashenko ha
funcionado en la práctica como un estado
satélite
por otro lado la unión europea ha sido
durante muchos años muy dura y crítica
con el régimen por la represión y falta
de libertades y democracia
y represión que por ejemplo explica las
desapariciones en el 99 y en el 2000 de
dos políticos opositores un empresario y
un periodista algo que hizo que la unión
europea impusiera sanciones económicas y
restricciones comerciales al país
y es que no no penséis ni por un segundo
que lukashenko es un tipo al que le
guste disimular su ramalazo autoritario
todo lo contrario de hecho incluso le
gusta hacer bromas sobre ello como esta
que hizo en una entrevista en 2012 para
reuters soy el único y último dictador
en europa de hecho no hay ningún otro en
ningún lugar del mundo has venido aquí
ya has visto a un dictador viviente
donde más podrías ver 1 alexander
lukashenko vamos que eso de ser dictador
le gusta más que a mourinho ver perder a
guardiola sin embargo frente a todos los
pronósticos a pesar del fuerte carácter
de lukashenko lo cierto es que en los
últimos cuatro años se ha producido una
gran mejora de las relaciones entre
bielorrusia y la unión europea
una mejora las relaciones bilaterales
que por ejemplo llevo aquí en 2016 la
unión europea retirará las sanciones
contra tres empresas y 170 altos cargos
o personas cercanas al régimen aún se
mantienen otras sanciones como por
ejemplo el embargo a la venta de armas
pero fue significativo una muestra de
que a pesar de todo las cosas podrían
mejorar es decir que parece que la unión
europea se ha puesto las pilas con
bielorrusia en eso que se ha venido a
llamar la realpolitik es decir la
política pasada pura y exclusivamente en
intereses prácticos
que bielorrusia es una dictadura si eso
está claro pero amigos que la unión
europea se lleve bien con bielorrusia
puede ser algo así como meterle el dedo
en el ojo al mismísimo vladimir putin y
es que si hay algo busca en este caso la
unión europea es tratar de debilitar el
poder y la influencia de putin
y bielorrusia es para el gobierno de
vladímir putin un país clave su último
aliado
ferré o algo así como ese hijo
predilecto al que protege cueste lo que
cueste pero del que de vez en cuando
también necesita algún que otro favor
por eso a putin ese tímido pero
constante acercamiento de la unión
europea' le está resultando todo un
dolor de cabeza dicho de otra forma que
en la relación de la unión europea' con
bielorrusia lo menos importante es
precisamente bielorrusia
el caso es que durante la última década
el comercio con la unión europea ha
vuelto a despegar y sobre todo hay que
destacar que bielorrusia ha empezado a
recibir fondos comunitarios
concretamente 110 millones de euros del
conocido como instrumento europeo de
vecindad entre los años 2014 y 2018
sí vale eso es una minucia en
comparación con lo que a lo largo de los
años ha aportado rusia pero muestra una
clara mejora en las relaciones entre
minsk y bruselas al fin y al cabo en
otras circunstancias no vas por ahí
regalando decenas y decenas de millones
de euros bueno la verdad es que con la
unión europea nunca se sabe
el caso es que llegados a este punto hay
una pregunta clave como han sido y cómo
están hoy exactamente las relaciones
entre rusia y bielorrusia dos países
hasta ahora hermanos dos países que
pocos años después de la caída de la
unión soviética llegaron incluso a
estudiar su integración política sí sí
así es una integración progresiva eso
fue exactamente lo que acordaron el
propio lukashenko y el entonces
presidente ruso borís yeltsin en 1999
ese año crearon una estructura
supranacional llamada integrar poco a
poco a los dos estados una estructura
con nombre y apellido el estado de la
unión
[Música]
ahora bien seguro que a muchos os cherry
a la idea de que alguien como lukashenko
un tipo con una ambición de poder tan
grande estuviera dispuesto a integrarse
con rusia lo que evidentemente no nos
engañemos le hubiera dado todo el poder
a moscú
[Música]
entonces qué fue lo que llevó a
lukashenko a pactar esa integración con
boris yeltsin es que acaso pensaba que
los rusos le iban a regalar el poder
[Música]
amigos para entender la idea de
lukashenko la de rusia y cómo ha
cambiado todo este tema últimamente
dejad que os explicamos en qué consistía
todo esto del estado de la unión un
proyecto tan disparatado que nació si es
que en algún momento llegó a nacer con
heridas fatales atentos
estado de la unión la absorción que
nunca llegan camaradas de visual
político tal y como os acabamos de
contar hace un momento esto del estado
de la unión se acordó en 1999 entre
lukashenko y el zinc
y el zinc no era putin ni lukashenko
sabía tanto de ser un sátrapa como todo
lo que ha aprendido desde entonces pero
que pretendían realmente el sin
lukashenko en el momento en el que se
acordó semejante cosa
por un lado rusia buscaba básicamente
pegarle un golpe en la espinilla a la
otan que en esos momentos acababa de
expandir a polonia república checa y
hungría expansión que dejaba las fuerzas
del tratado del atlántico norte
prácticamente a las puertas de rusia
moscú necesitaba un contrapeso fuera
como fuera tenía que jugar sus cartas
para frenar el avance de la otan y
demostrar que seguía siendo una
superpotencia y el contrapeso empezó con
su fiel aliado hermano de sangre y de
ideología bielorrusia
el caso es que la unión que se planteó
creaba una entidad supranacional en la
que poco a poco ambos países se
integrarían en una especie de bloque
político y económico si teóricamente
ambos países conservarían su soberanía
política y territorial pero las
decisiones tanto en política económica
como en política exterior y defensa
serían tomadas por este nuevo órgano en
la práctica se planteaba una integración
muy fuerte
[Música]
si no sólo eso el objetivo de rusia es
que esta unión fuera mucho más allá y
terminará creando incluso hasta una
moneda común un parlamento único una
constitución única tribunales propios
etcétera etcétera
es decir crear un mega bloque ruso al
mejor estilo de la unión soviética
sin embargo amigos pronto aparecieron
las reticencias del pacto o sonaba muy
bien pero cómo repartir el poder y el
poder esa era la pregunta pues veréis
aunque parezca mentira todo apunta a que
en un primer momento el propio
lukashenko ciego de ambición pensó que
la unión podría convertirlo a él mismo
en el líder plenipotenciario de nuevo
mega bloque y de esta forma dirigir no
sólo los destinos de bielorrusia sino
también los de la propia rusia es decir
aunque puede resultar sorprendente la
jugada que tenía en mente en lukashenko
era algo así como una especie de copa
donde el pequeño se comía al grande
soñar es gratis
el problema amigos es que putin no es
yersin y la rusia de hoy tampoco se
parece mucho a la rusia en caída libre
de finales de los años 90
en otras palabras al tirano bielorruso
tiro le salió por la culata
lukashenko nunca consiguió sus objetivos
y con el paso de los años al tiempo que
vladimir putin afianzaba su poder y lo
rusia se iba convirtiendo cada vez más
en una economía aislada de europa y
totalmente dependiente de rusia
hasta el punto de que el llamado estado
de la unión llegó a significar sólo dos
cosas para bielorrusia anexión o
chantaje fijaos porque durante los
últimos 20 años rusia ha utilizado las
ventas de petróleo y gas natural a
precios por debajo del mercado para
consolidar su influencia en minsk el
coste para rusia de esta política ha
sido elevadísimo algunos cálculos como
los del ministro de finanzas ruso anton
siluanov apuntan a más de 2 mil millones
de dólares
y ojito a la jugada durante este tiempo
lukashenko ha estado haciendo un negocio
año a año la economía bielorrusa se ha
especializado en la transformación
petrolera en las refinerías en la
exportación de combustibles de esta
forma a medida que las negociaciones
para lograr el estado de la unión se
congelaban lukashenko seguía sacando
partido a los acuerdos vigentes
[Música]
y claro como os podéis imaginar llegó un
punto en que rusia se cansó de esperar
sin recibir nada a cambio en cierto modo
vladimir putin sintió que los bienes
rusos que estaban tomando el pelo
[Música]
y amigos no no no con putin no se juega
en 2019 moscú empezó a condicionar los
contratos petroleros a los progresos en
la construcción del estado de la unión
es decir sin avances no habría más
petróleo ruso amos que putin le dijo
algo así como ándate con ojo luca yo te
portas bien o te quito el zoom hito de
dinosaurio tú verás russian si no a
bielorrusia que se una un estado
unificado a cambio de un acuerdo
petrolero y amigos es justo aquí cuando
se desató la crisis una lucha a cara de
perro entre los dos líderes atentos
[Música]
el gran giro traición o lucha por
existir hasta el pasado año 2019
lukashenko decía una y otra vez cosas
como esta ambos podríamos unirnos mañana
sin problemas
alexander lukashenko sin embargo a
comienzos del 2020 la retórica ha
cambiado bastante fijaos tenemos nuestro
propio país somos soberanos e
independientes y no podemos ser parte de
otro país no puedo traicionar o si
disolver bielorrusia incluso nuestra
hermana rusia si llego a acordar eso los
cielos rusos me comerían vivo en un año
es honorable ser el primer presidente y
estoy seguro de que no quiero ser el
último
alexander lukashenko es como si de
repente hubiese despertado en lukashenko
un espíritu nacionalista y soberanista
que antes no existía
ahora bien realmente va en serio o es
simplemente una estrategia de presión
para sacarle más y más concesiones a
moscú a sabiendas de que quizás putin
necesita a bielorrusia para perpetuarse
en el poder
un momento de putin puede necesitar a su
vecino para mantenerse en el poder pues
sí si lo habéis escuchado bien
actualmente el presidente ruso está
desarrollando varios planes para poder
mantenerse en el poder más allá del 2024
y uno de esos planes podría pasar
precisamente por bielorrusia
la estrategia sería la siguiente si
rusia bielorrusia terminan de crear un
nuevo estado un nuevo ente de gobierno
diferente al de la federación rusa que
engloba los países útil podría ser
presidente de ese nuevo estado ya que
estaría sujeto a una nueva constitución
con unas nuevas condiciones y con un
nuevo estatus de poder es decir putin
volvería a ser presidente pero no de la
federación rusa sino del estado de la
unión de rusia y bielorrusia
sea como sea parece que la disputa va en
serio
en enero las exportaciones de petróleo
de rusia bielorrusia se desplomaron un
75% respecto a lo previsto y es que
rusia redujo las entregas en un millón y
medio de toneladas
y como ya os hemos contado en la
economía bielorrusa la industria
petroquímica tiene mucha importancia así
que esto ha obligado a lukashenko a
elegir entre dos caminos o rendirse a
moscú o tratar de encontrar otros amigos
que les suministren todo el combustible
que necesita para que el país no se
venga abajo
y ahí hay donde han aparecido nuevos
amigos fijaos bielorrusia comienza a
importar petróleo de noruega tras la
interrupción rusa pero no se trata solo
de noruega jens ha encontrado de repente
a otro salvador un país que lleva diez
años sin mediar palabra diplomáticamente
con bielorrusia y que ahora de repente
quiere restablecer al cien por cien las
relaciones diplomáticas a alguna idea
atentos
[Música]
el robot
pero visita a bielorrusia mientras los
lazos de minsk o moscú se desgastan eeuu
quiere ayudar a bielorrusia a construir
su propio país soberano nuestros
productores están 100% listos para
proporcionar todo el petróleo que
necesitéis a precios competitivos
vuestra nación no debería verse forzada
a depender de ningún socio para tener
prosperidad y seguridad mike pompeo
secretario de estado de eeuu no digáis
que no es una jugada maestra
[Música]
sin embargo lo cierto es que a pesar de
conseguir nuevos proveedores
hoy por hoy bielorrusia está sufriendo
una acuciante escasez de petróleo que ya
ha provocado la suspensión de las
exportaciones petroquímicas
exportaciones que el país necesita para
obtener divisas dólares
y eso eso es precisamente lo que ha
llevado al dictador bielorruso a hacer
uso de su penúltima bala a amenazar con
robarle a rusia parte de sus
exportaciones de crudo aprovechando que
el oleoducto de druzhba por el que rusia
exporta petróleo a europa pasa
precisamente por su territorio la última
bala sería robárselo bielorrusia amenaza
con sacar petróleo ruso con destino a
europa
sea como sea tal y como veis las
relaciones entre putin y lukashenko
están que arden vamos al borde de
bloquearse mutuamente en el whatsapp
el presidente bielorruso se está
empezando a arrimar a occidente para
evitar que su aislamiento propicie una
temida invasión rusa al estilo de crimea
y que se expide solos en el mundo y sin
nadie que les defienda bueno sin nadie
que defienda a lukashenko y a su sillón
y desde luego ya os podéis imaginar que
eso de amenazar con robar el petróleo
ruso en moscú no ha sentado nada pero
que nada bien
os imaginais la cara de putin si su
petróleo empezará a desaparecer de los
oleoductos si hablar y si si soy yo luca
dime dime no puede ser verdad como que
no ha llegado el petróleo por chico aquí
no hemos visto nada eh
mira tú no te preocupes que si yo veo
algo te digo en fin
así están las cosas en la que sería la
última batalla del loco escenario de
europa del este en visual política
estaremos atentos a cómo puedan
desarrollarse los acontecimientos pero
mientras tanto tú qué piensas se ha
ganado rusia el derecho a controlar a su
vecino por todo el petróleo que le han
entregado en condiciones preferentes
conseguirá el presidente ruso salirse
con la suya y anexionarse al país vecino
realmente él lukashenko está dispuesto a
girar hacia occidente deja nuestra
respuesta en los comentarios ya sabéis
si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]